Congressman, do you think the president
shooting this thing down
was the right decision?
What do you make of this object?
As little as we
I mean, it's not the right decision.
It's it's it's a mystery.
I mean, obviously,
it doesn't appear to be a balloon
like we dealt with all of last week.
Evidently, it hung around.
I've heard that it's not maneuverable.
There's a lot of stuff
out there in the air,
on the Internet,
on Twitter describing it,
which I don't know
if it's true or just rumor,
but it's certainly to me,
looks like something that either
China or Russia,
you know, I guess it's
quite possible
that there could be
some commercial entity
that was testing something.
But given the proximity
to military bases,
and stuff with our defense,
it's it's very interesting.
And I think there's a lot we
we may not even find out,
but there's a lot to be learned.
Is there anything
I mean,
in this area in particular
that would have been of
interest to adversaries?
Well, there's
air defense, there's military
bases, there's fighter bases.
There's some energy intense
stuff up there.
Alaska actually plays
a very important role
in national defense, particularly
when you're looking at to its west.
You look at Russia
and you look at
around the globe to China.
So, yeah,
I mean,
it could be anything from that level.
But I mean,
it's really kind
of an interesting mystery.
And I think they made the absolute
right decision to shoot it down
I'm not sure if it was shot down
because of,
you know, commercial airline traffic,
as they've said.
I think that's probably
the right thing to say.
But look, it's
pretty sparsely populated out there.
And you can always vector
traffic around something.
So I certainly think
they saw it as a threat
if it does turn out to be China
or another adversary like Russia.
What happens then?
I mean,
obviously, countries
probe each other all the time,
looking for,
you know,
trying to trying to spy on each other.
Should there be other action?
No, I don't think it should escalate.
I mean, you know,
I think it's
it does end up being China or Russia.
We obviously should be concerned.
And I think we've made it clear
the president has made it clear
and DOD has made it clear
that we're not going to allow incursions
into our airspace.
And so,
you know,
if China wants to put something
up, a balloon in some cases
or maybe possibly
whatever this object was,
it's going to cost them that
because we will defend our airspace.
And I think that's the right call
because that's the way
you actually stop
this kind of encroachment from happening,
is you make it clear
it will be a waste of money
because we're going to take it down.
Do you think some
I mean, you were sort of indicating this
you know, the argument is, well,
it was said at commercial
air traffic level.
It does seem like
some of the reaction to this
may have been just based on the criticism
the Biden administration had received for
for waiting on the Chinese spy balloon.
It's certainly possible.
But it's also you look at,
you know,
did they gather intelligence
when the spy balloon came over?
Evidently, we did.
And I think from that point,
so you can allow it
to traverse the country
once, get whatever intelligence
you need to.
But we can't allow
something like that again.
So as a response
to political pressure, possibly,
I doubt the DOD
would recommend shooting something down
because of the politics of it.
I would think that at this point,
we're making it very clear
that you basically got one chance
to fly something over our country
and after that,
you're not going to make it in. Yeah.
Congressman Kinzinger,
appreciate your time.
Thanks so much.
Want to get perspective now
for James
Clapper, former
director of national intelligence
and currently a CNN
national security analyst.
Also, William Cohen,
who served as defense secretary
during the Clinton administration
as Secretary Cohen.
How much in your view
was this about neutralizing
a threat to civilian aircraft
and how much about sending a message to
the American population and
also other countries?
I don't think the altitude
was really the dispositive factor here.
Let's assume that the object was flying
at 50,000 feet or 60,000 feet.
I think the answer would have I'm
a little shot down anyway.
So that may have been a factor involved,
but I think that was not
the dominant reason.
I think you're sending a message
to whoever sent this up,
whether it was China or Russia
or some other country.
If you invade in our airspace,
we're going to take it out.
Now, there's a cost to it.
I'm sorry, Congressman.
Hasn't you said there's a cost to them.
There's a cost to us.
Those Sidewinder
missiles cost about 380 $400,000.
So every time they put a cheap balloon up
or some other object,
we have to take it down.
It's not without expense to us as well.
Now, I doubt
if that's the cost formula
going into effect right now.
I think
I think it was right to take it down,
and I think it was right to wait on the
the first Chinese balloon
that went to dredge clapper.
I mean, the U.S.
released very few details about
the object shot down.
Would they have photographed it
before shooting it down?
I mean, would
they have actually had eyes on it?
Do you think
Well, I don't know.
Hopefully they did or had some indication
of the nature of its payload.
It would appear, though, that
just from its its size, that
it didn't represent the technology
that apparently
was represented on the Chinese balloon.
So I do think, if I may,
just a broader comment,
I do think it would be very useful
as this situation evolves
if administration could devise a protocol
that could be explained to the Congress
and to the public
as what the ground rules are on
when and where and under
what conditions
would shoot one down or what
all those conditions
that we would want to observe it
for intelligence purposes.
Now, speaking purely
as an intelligence guy,
I was
amused a bit by
those who were complaining about it.
This the Chinese balloon
being an intelligence failure.
But you're also complaining
because we took the time
to learn something about it.
And it's not like we can fly over
China and observe one of their balloons.
So this was an opportunity
to gain intelligence.
And so I think that
that may have been a valid argument
all to say.
I think it would be a good thing
if we had a protocol.
It could be explained both to the public
and especially the Congress
about the suggestion of ground rules.
So, General Clapper,
one can gather intel
in the balloon incident.
You can gather intelligence
just by following the balloon,
watching it, reading signals
off it or something.
Well,
yes.
And if you can observe it
up close and personal,
you can learn a lot about, for example,
at antenna design up
there,
you can do forensics on the antennas
that figure out,
you know, that
the nature of where
there might have been
a transmitter or a receiver
which is very useful to know
if you're going to continue
to glean intelligence on what
just what one of these things is doing.
So there are and the other
part of
this is there are ways to collect
intelligence on the balloon
that is not directly connected
physically with the balloon itself.
So if we have some insight into its
launch facilities
and the protocols
the Chinese use
when they launch, that's
all valuable stuff.
And particularly
if you can connect that
with the actual operation of the balloon
as it's flying.
Secretary Cohen,
do you do you agree with that,
with the Director Clapper,
that there should be
some sort of publicly announced protocols
or at least explained protocols?
I think
General Clapper
is absolutely correct
in terms
of making sure that Congress is on board.
One of the things that's taking place is
everybody is trying to be a quick draw.
McCraw come out and say,
who's got the fastest gun in the West?
And I think what we have,
what we saw
is this administration
acting and our military acting
with restraint
to first understand
what the object was
in the Chinese balloon.
See, if we get intelligence
that General Clapper was saying
but there was something else
that came out of that.
We found out that we knew
several years ago
that they were doing this.
It wasn't disclosed
because we didn't
want the Chinese to know that we knew
And that's something that's important.
So bring the Congress in the Big Eight
and sit down with them
and let them know
what's going on in terms
of how we're going to approach it
in the future.
You'll have less people coming out
and being critical.
And Political Director Clapper.
U.S.
intelligence officials indicated
they don't believe that Chinese President
Xi was aware of an order
to send the spy balloon over the U.S.
if the latest object
turns out to be China again.
I mean, do you.
First of all, do you
do you do you buy that that
the president wouldn't
have known the president?
You wouldn't have known that
No, I don't.
The Chinese setup is
there is a Politburo member
who is the overseer, the senior overseer
on behalf of the Politburo
for the entirety of the intelligence
and security apparatus of China,
which is mammoth and is multi.
They have
many many organizations
and agencies that are involved in this.
So it's hard for me to believe that
a Politburo member
was directly associated with President Xi
would not have informed
President Xi about it.
So I don't buy that. Interesting.
General Clapper,
Secretary Cohen, I appreciate it.
Thank you.